pues si raúl hoy se cumplen cinco años
desde que el acuerdo de parís entró en
vigor y por ello no es casualidad que
dediquen el día como bien lo decía a la
energía que es el sector responsable de
dos terceras partes de los gases de
efecto invernadero van a estar
discutiendo los ministros presentes
durante en la con 26 como transición ar
a una economía y a una sociedad menos
basada en esos combustibles fósiles y
poder tener una red de lerche energética
basada en energías renovables porque por
ahora el carbón sigue siendo el rey de
la energía con un 37 por ciento de la
producción de electricidad seguida del
gas natural en cuanto a las renovables
la primera esta es la hidroeléctrica con
un 16 por ciento sin embargo esta manera
de conseguir energía es bastante
polémica porque produce o representa
bastantes interrupciones en la
biodiversidad y en la fauna y la flora
de las zonas donde se instalan las
represas y también es una lucha
constante de las poblaciones indígenas
porque para ellos las represas suelen
ser siempre problemas y causa de
bastantes asesinatos de líderes
ambientales de hecho la eólica es la
segunda energía renovable con 5,3 por
ciento y la solar con 2,6 y como bien
decía sabido habrá varios anuncios
durante la jornada de hoy que acaba de
comenzar realmente y chile estará entre
esos países que se van a comprometer a
ir cerrando las plantas de carbón ya no
abrir ninguna nueva
ahora marina lo estamos viendo a sus
espaldas ahora mismo usted no está en
las instalaciones de la cob sino una
huerta vertical cuéntenos un poco acerca
de esta y por qué es importante en el
contexto de la lucha contra el cambio
climático
pues sí estoy rodeada de plantas de
albahaca de hecho toda la instalación
que está a unos pocos metros de hecho de
la zona azul y de la zona verde que son
las instalaciones oficiales de la cob 26
está bueno todo estoy rodeado como bien
decía de plantas de albahaca y toda esta
instalación huele a albahaca así que es
una maravilla es una de las
instalaciones que han puesto aquí
temporalmente durante la cop 26 para que
la gente pueda venir y enterarse acerca
de los beneficios de esta agricultura
vertical en este caso tienen bandejas de
6 metros cuadrados con un montón de
plantas y lo que quieren es demostrar
como este tipo de agricultura no sólo
beneficia a la seguridad alimentaria de
miles de personas ya que se puede
producir en cualquier lugar tanto en
zonas rurales como en urbanas y además
tiene un consumo de co2 mucho menor y un
consumo de agua muchísimo menor porque
toda el agua que se utiliza para regar
estas plantas se recicla y es circular y
no hay ningún tipo de lixiviado de
fertilizantes tampoco porque al estar en
un ambiente controlado hay menos
menos oportunidades para que hongos o
virus se metan en estas plantas así que
no hay que utilizar ningún tipo de
químico para fertilizar las es un tipo
de agricultura que podría beneficiar al
acceso como bien lo decía porque se
puede cultivar en cualquier lado también
reduciría los los costos y las emisiones
del transporte porque podríamos tenerlo
cerca de casa o incluso en nuestra
propia casa y cultivar nuestra comida y
así evitar tener que transportar la
comida y emitir gases de efecto
invernadero como bien lo decía esto va a
reducir el consumo de agua significan
significativamente porque la agricultura
se lleva el 70 por ciento del consumo
del agua mundial